okay great I guess we're gonna start so
it's my pleasure to welcome John Dench
who is a close collaborator of niccolo
and myself and we're very excited to
have him talk here because we know he's
a fabulous speaker and so John is the
associate director of the genetic
perturbation platform at the broad and
he develops and applies a bunch of
really cool stuff and lots of other
stuff and so okay great thanks Jennifer
and thanks all for coming out I heard
from Jennifer that these meetings can be
informal so if you have any questions
obviously just shout it out as we go I'm
totally happy to be interrupted as we go
yeah so genetic screens grippers so
first you know our genome is kind of a
mess you know it's kind of a dumpster
fire of information so imagine you did
this you went to Ikea and you bought
20,000 different things you bought a
Klondike and a flip door pin and knock
top and you mix all the parts together
on your living room rug and then you
burnt all the instructions and so you
just have this pile of parts and some
Allen wrenches and you're trying to
figure out how do I build all these
things and that's kind of what our
genome looks like because our genome was
the product of three and a half billion
years a very short term thinking right a
genome just exists to get to the next
day so you know can you imagine like
just okay most people here probably have
coated in their past if you were still
working on the original piece of code
that you wrote when you were 12 and you
just kept appending everything to that
as you went as you went as you went
that's kind of what our genome looks
like but you can imagine them to get
pretty messy so trying to figure out
what all these parts do is actually
quite challenging so you know here's the
brief history of biology in a couple of
slides so Gregor Mendel asked the
question what is a gene and you know
this is an xkcd cartoon that is actually
true on my second date with my now wife
we realized there's a 50% chance that
we'd have a blue-eyed child and so I
continued to date her and we do have a
blue-eyed child is correct but this is
really private you know Gregor Mendel
his work with the pea plants you know
that you that you could you know he
could breathe these different peas and
then you know they could be round and
they could be green and it could be
yellow yeah
that there were trades on whether you
could predict the future that is really
powerful right
I mean biology as a discipline used to
be well there's a beetle let's give it a
name there's a bird let's give it a name
you know it's very classification based
it was not you know there was not a
science and they like with physics the
really cool part about physics is you
know if you know you know the angle of a
plane and a ball on the friction you can
predict how long is Negra that ball to
roll down or you can predict well if
Jupiter's here now it's gonna be over
there in 30 years right the ability to
predict the future is really a really
cool part of science and this was the
first time that anything that we could
consider biology you could really start
to predict the future the idea that
traits are heritable and that Nature has
rules
but then it was about a hundred years
before we figured out well what is a
gene made of and of course a gene is
made of DNA you know this is the
structure of DNA the double helix
there's Watson and Crick and you know
this is both the first and last time
that Jim Watson was ever understated
when they concluded the paper by saying
it has not escaped our notice that the
specific pairing we have postulated
immediately suggests a possible copying
mechanism for the genetic material if
you know one strand of DNA you know the
other if you have two strands that's how
you can transmit information across
generations so once we know what a gene
is made of you can ask the question well
what are all the genes and that was the
human genome project human genome
project it's hard to say a precise
beginning an end but it was basically
from the mid 80s through the 90s and
then kind of culminated towards the end
towards the beginning of the of the 2000
so you know you this is the human genome
for you know pages and pages and pages
who knows how many bases are in the
human genome raise your hand if you want
to be bold and make it guess no one here
is bold enough to make a guess about how
many bases are in the human genome
okay MIT boy what is it how many you
took 701 with Eric Lander correct he was
the sequin genome project and you took
701 how many bases are in the human
genome no don't look to her for help
given number as long as you don't answer
like a letter you're fine a hundred
billion okay who thinks it is more than
a hundred billion who thinks it is less
than a hundred billion okay if you okay
good participatory democracy good yes it
is less than 100
there are about 3 billion bases in the
human genome yeah I mean again you
didn't guess a month so that's good ok
but you know the genome itself you know
Lander was asked to summarize it in
seven in seven words and he said genome
bought the book hard to read which is
another way of saying you know all these
bases don't make a lot of sense and
unlike an Ikea product you can't just
call up Sweden and find out well what
how do I actually put this things
together so what is all this information
in our genome so by 2001 this is where
we were and so we have the sequence of
the human genome but we don't really
know what the genes do we can say AHA
this is a gene you know they're features
of okay this is protein coding and is
likely to be a splice site there are all
these things you can point to it in the
genome and say okay here's a gene here's
a unit of information we don't know what
they do we don't have a function for the
vast majority of genes and I swear that
we still don't have a function for the
vast majority of genes we know it's a
big hockey stick we know a lot about a
small number of genes and almost nothing
about the vast majority okay so given a
DNA sequence we now have it right you
can go to the internet and look up the
human genome how do you determine a
function so we have we have this we have
the top we have the the DNA the the
genotype okay but we don't know the
phenotype so how do you break the flow
of information to figure out okay if I
have this information what is it
actually doing in the cell so how do we
maybe start to break apart this system
yes a phenotype is okay that's a good
question
so if you know so a genotype is again
what's in the DNA the phenotype could be
curly hair it could be blue eyes it
could be intelligence it could be height
it could be proclivity to vote for
Donald Trump anything that you can
measure anything that an organism can do
or a trait of an organism that is a
phenotype and you know how does this
information get Trant get transcribed in
the language of messenger RNA then get
translated into a protein and then
usually it's the proteins that
ultimately give rise to phenotypes
you know these proteins are the stuff
that are mostly doing stuff inside cells
so given a sequence how do we determine
a function so in the year 2003 Fortune
magazine wrote this they wrote that
advance is that when Nobel Prize are
uncommon ones worth billions of dollars
or even scarcer and those yielding both
are Bluemoon rare in biotech and this is
rate
and biotech there had been just two blue
moons first was recombinant DNA
technology so the ability to take DNA
and move it around and in in bacteria
that was in the 1970s and then
monoclonal antibodies which are now a
therapeutic modality and that's kind of
what made Genentech a very popular
company
but then they wrote okay there's this
new technology called RNA interference
or RNAi I and they were very excited
about it and they say okay first within
a few years we have a rough idea of what
each of our genes does that turned out
not to be true we still don't know this
is written in 2003 we still don't know
but also the point of that gene
medicines have long been a biotech Grail
okay so this is where we were in 2003 we
have this technology called RNA
interference or RNAi AI that we're going
to use to try to figure out what genes
do and here's the very basic mechanism
of RNAi I you put double strand RNA into
a cell one of the strands gets chosen by
this protein that's called risk that's
what this circle is and this RNA then
base pairs to any messenger RNA that has
the same sequence and cuts it and gets
rid of it okay so this is another way of
saying if we go back to this graph or
this schematic that if we know the
sequence of a gene we can introduce into
the cell an RNA that will base pair to
this and if it base pairs to this it
gets rid of it okay so that's a very
basic mechanism for our ad but it's a
way of saying okay if we know the
sequence of a gene we can eliminate its
messenger RNA and then try to figure out
well if this protein is gone what was
that protein doing so that that's what
RNA I does but the problem with RNA AI
is that it turned and people were very
excited about this now you I'm gonna
talk about CRISPR in a bit which you may
have heard of it's been a little bit
hyped but there was just as much hype or
almost just as much hype for RNA I in
the early 2000s okay there was a lot of
promise behind it but some chinks in the
armor merge so here's a data set we're
on the y-axis I'm plotting messenger RNA
changes in expression okay so you
measure messenger RNA in a Cell you ask
what genes go up what genes go down that
is a technology that's been with us for
a while now and what
put it on the x-axis are just a bunch of
different treatments okay so the first
two are if you do nothing to the cell
this is just the standard variation in
gene expression across measurements
pretty small error here's another one
where we do a vector treatment so it's
sort of a control treatment where we
don't add anything and then each of
these is a different small RNA sequence
that we've added to the cells but we've
added them to the cells and way where
they don't have a target okay we are not
actually targeting a gene in the human
genome and what you see is that all of
them cause very large gene expression
changes so by definition since there is
no on target activity for these things
that has to be off target activity and
in fact we now know that this is the
case because there is actually two
pathways for RNA i in cells so you put
in your small RNA and this is what you
want it to do you want it to bind to a
single messenger RNA and cut it and
allow you to study that messenger RNA
but what can also happen there's another
pathway in the cells where only a small
number of nucleotides so six to eight
nucleotides so the full thing is 20
nucleotides or so and that's what you
want for full specificity that's a lot
of information content 20 nucleotides
but another pathway uses only six to
eight nucleotides and regulates many
many many different messenger RNAs and
that drives all basically all of this
off target activity so we looked at the
very large data set and we said where we
had gene expression data so I already
showed this first part where shrna is
you know these are nai triggers that are
targeting genes that are not expressed
in cells you know they are all off
target activity they can also kill cells
that's a pretty dramatic phenotype cell
death like they're clearly doing
something in cells what we could do is
we could classify two different small
rnas either two rnas meant to target the
same gene so here's just one random gene
the gene b raf here are two different
sequences meant to target that gene okay
so if the effect of the perturbation is
on target then they should have the same
gene expression change because it's a
non target change however we also can
look at ones that have this same six to
eight
nucleotide stretch in a particular
position that have this same off-target
effect and ask how similar are these two
when we classify our pretty large data
set of measuring thousands of these
things in gene expression space and what
we can see is that so here's the
correlation between them null
distribution showed in the dotted red to
RNA I triggers that are meant to target
the same gene have us you know you could
fit a late I will show you you can fit a
laser pointer in here so if this were a
therapy the FDA would approve it because
you can fit that in there but it's
clearly not a very large correlations
did this at least significant but minor
whereas two rnas that have this same
seed sequence that have this same off
target profile correlate far more
readily so that led to the observation
this was a editorial published by Bill
Callen colleague of ours at Dana Farber
saying look the honeymoon is over for
RNA I and whether you're married to a
technology or a human that is a phrase
you never want to hear okay and he said
the reason that RNA I was so hyped but
that has fallen out of favor are these
off-target effects so this is a very
challenging time in functional genomics
because this was our only tool to study
gene function we had this human genome
right we had spent as a country we had
spent millions or billions of dollars to
make this thing and this was our only
tool of probing gene function but it has
a pretty clear problem to it however
fortunately evolution has been working
on this problem for a while and there's
more than one way to use small rnas to
determine gene sequence
and may the fourth be with you okay so
evolution had been working on this
problem for a while there there's a
there's a problem in in life okay so
this is this is what Douglas Adams wrote
in the Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy
somewhere in the deep remote past this
force that he's talking about seriously
traumatized a small random group of
atoms drifting through space these
patterns quickly learn to copy
themselves and they went on to cause
massive trouble on every planet they
drifted on to and that was how life
began in the universe okay
so this is basically another way of
saying look there are these viruses
there are these selfish genetic elements
that just exist to do nothing but copy
themselves and these are of course
problems to organisms okay so small rnas
are a way that evolution has come up
with so this RNA I pathway that
originally arose as a way for cells to
control viral infection and it turns out
there is another pathway to control
viral infection even more ancient and
that is CRISPR
so now CRISPR is has really penetrated
public's consciousness I haven't watched
it but apparently was in the final
finale of the x-files reboot and it is
estimated to be a very very large know
as valuable as Dunkin Donuts in a couple
years which is rather big this so what
what is CRISPR so the story of CRISPR
actually begins with an interesting day
in a yogurt Factory and if you search or
Bing did you verb Bing okay if you Bing
an interesting day and a yogurt factory
being tells you that there has never
been an interesting day in a yogurt
Factory but I can assure you there is at
least once an interesting day in a
yogurt factory so to grow yogurt to make
yogurt you need back two different
strains of bacteria so in this one
yogurt factory they're growing s
thermophilus so this is you know it's
one of those strains in your stony field
yogurt oh this did not occur it
Stonyfield and one day viral
contamination swept through the yogurt
plant and that is not good because now
you've gone from happily growing as
thermophilus to mostly dead s
thermophilus and you can't make any
yogurt so that is not good however there
were some molecular biologists working
for this company and what they did is
they sequenced the DNA
from the original strain that was
sensitive the viral DNA to the small
number and then sequenced the DNA from
the small fraction of bacteria that
survived this viral infection and it
found that the only difference in the
genome of these two was that there were
small clips of viral DNA in what was
termed the CRISPR locus in the cells
that survives so they made the
conclusion turned out to be right that
the bacteria had acquired viral sequence
put it into his own genome and used that
sequence to fight off the virus yeah yes
same virus that contaminated I will show
you that right now in fact okay so how
does CRISPR actually work so there's
kind of three phases to this CRISPR
system okay in the first phase a virus
squirts its DNA into a cell and there
are proteins in the bacteria that
recognize it as foreign DNA and chop it
up and shove it into its own genome and
this is actually where the term CRISPR
comes from CRISPR stands for clustered
regularly interspaced short palindromic
repeats and and they were originally
observed in genomes I think in the year
2002 was when the phrase was coined long
before anyone had any idea what they did
they just realized well here's a
structural feature of a genome that
there are these clustered so they're all
together regularly interspaced so
there's you know here's a block his
block is a block is a block here's a
block with these sequences between them
short palindromic repeats so these these
black boxes are short and they have a
little bit of palindrome structure to
them's like hairpin structure and
they're just repeated over and over and
it was realized like Oh a lot of
different bacteria have low-side that
looked like this but they did not know
the function it wasn't until the yogurt
people came along and realized ah the
sequences in here are viral sequences
this must be an immune system that the
cells are using to see a virus so you
see a virus and you then put a memory of
that virus into your own genome okay in
the next phase
you then express that DNA into an RNA
and then there are other enzymes that
chop up that RNA into individual
snippets one for each block that was
inserted okay those are the colors and
then in the final step anything that
this can base pair to any stretch of DNA
that this can base pair to gets cut by
another protein okay so this is a way
that a cell can see a virus make a
memory of it and then fight it off
either at the same time or in the future
and what's really neat is if you look at
the these actually do get added in order
so basically you know new ones get at it
at the front as older ones get shoved
off to the side
so you actually are you know are
acquiring a memory of you know what
order and organism has actually seen
these things now this is a revolutionary
because in you know I don't when when I
was in my early 20s and some people here
might be in their early 20s you kind of
think you know everything right like you
get to graduate school and you know okay
I know what I'm gonna study I know what
the next revolution is gonna be in
biotechnology no one in their right mind
went to study bacteria right I mean we
all okay we're gonna study but millions
I was gonna say can't circus a diabetes
we're gonna do something that's gonna
have a real impact and almost no one
went to study bacteria they do that
ecoli okay this lab strain that had been
used for decades if there was anything
new to learn about e.coli was insane
well apparently not bacteria still had
more tricks yeah so they it is it is
they're sort of always expressed and
surveying the you know whatever virus
might be around so obviously you know
there might be a virus that it doesn't
already have a CRISPR against and then
the virus wins that evolutionary race
but you know as long as you know in a
population of a billion bacteria so long
as a couple of them manage to do this
process before the invading bacteria
phage kills it then the then the then
the bacteria survives yeah it i mean
obviously bacteria there's tremendous
evolutionary pressure and many of them
to keep their genomes small so you know
obviously there
Gina was just getting bigger and bigger
bigger all the time I don't personally
know and maybe no one knows the
mechanism by which they degrade things
or they let that information die off at
the end but it clearly does happen
because you know there it can only hold
so many sequences now okay so yeah this
family as far as we know only exists in
bacteria but it's president about half
of all prokaryotes it's a very
ubiquitous pathway yeah as far as I'm
aware chromosomal although I'm sure that
you know somewhere out there there's a
prokaryote that decides to store its its
CRISPR sequences on a plasmid like it
would do it shock me if that weren't
true but in the ones that have been most
studied it is chromosomal okay so that's
how CRISPR works but how do we use it
how do we use RNA I first and then how
do we use CRISPR now to answer that
original question of well what do all
the genes in the genome actually do so
the nice part about the criticism is
that to put it into another organism of
interest such as human cells you really
only need two components you first need
that you only need these downstream
components right you don't need to
acquire an immune system all you need
are these file2 components that you can
reprogram to cut any DNA sequence of
interest okay and those two components
are this endonuclease called cast 9 and
then an RNA guide okay and this RNA
guide can be reprogrammed with about 20
nucleotides of specificity to base pair
to any stretch of nearly any stretch of
DNA that you want and when you introduce
this into a mammalian cell for example
and you generate a cut in DNA a double
strand DNA break the cell senses this
DNA damage and the way the cell repairs
this DNA damage is to glue it back but
the way it glues it back is somewhat
error-prone and it will often insert or
delete so IND L insert or delete a
couple of nucleotides so when it does
that if you've targeted this to a
protein coding region you know where the
frame is really important where these
three nucleotides code for one amino
acid these three nucleotides code for an
there if you've shifted the frame of
that by inserting a deletion a small
number of random nucleotides you
basically create a nonsense allele or
you've disrupted the ability of the cell
to make that protein anymore so you can
out just by knowing the sequence of a
gene express in RNA and provide this
protein and permanently alter the DNA of
that cell to no longer express that gene
so a quick comparison of RNA and CRISPR
this is is actually one of the first
CRISPR experiments we did in the lab
where we had a cell expressing gfp so it
has a single copy of green fluorescent
protein and this history it is on the
notice that this is on a log scale this
is a gram is okay here's how much GFP
these cells normally have we put in four
different sequences targeting or to
these six different sequences targeting
GFP put them into cells and then saw in
all cases we saw a basically complete
loss of any green fluorescence and we
saw a complete loss because we had now
eliminated we had changed the DNA and
these cells now no longer have the
information to express GFP now contrast
that to RNA I where we put in a small
RNA that uses the RNA I pathway not a
crisper pathway but the RNA I pathway
all of them work you know this histogram
is shifted to the left but we're
knocking down the amount of protein
we're not removing all the protein from
the cell so a difference in the in the
mechanism of these two and the and the
the purity of the phenotype okay so
really neat that we have these two
different small RNA pathways for loss of
function the RNA I machinery is found in
nearly all eukaryotes is a very early
invention and evolution of eukaryotes
because we find it in plants and animals
and fungi so almost certainly what was a
very early eukaryotic invention whereas
CRISPR Llosa are present in more than
half of all prokaryotes they both arose
originally to defend the genome against
invading genetic elements it's
interesting that they both hit on the
idea and as far as we know these did
evolve independently it's not like RNAi
I evolved from CRISPR as far as we know
right now but it is interesting that
they both landed on this idea of using a
small RNA with
20 nucleotides of specificity to clear
out these sequences all right now I was
first discovered in 98 and first used
him in millions was in 2001 the yogurt
experiment was done in 2007 and this was
first used in mammalian cells only a
couple years ago but what's really cool
from my perspective is that we now have
multiple tools that can manipulate all
the genes in the human genome and find
out what they do okay we can perturb
them at the level of DNA with CRISPR we
can perturb them at the level of RNA
with RNA I and find out what are these
things do it okay actually I'm gonna
skip that slide yes yeah so you know it
it does it isn't so just repeat the
question it seems RNA I is worse than
CRISPR why is evolution preserved at um
so that is a good question I think that
part of it is that it still does a good
job I mean you know if I go back to this
GFP example you know this is on a log
scale and these things you know there's
ten to a hundred fold loss of the
protein okay so you are you know you can
if you do a Western blot with a good RNA
I reagent you can see you you can't
detect the target protein like it really
does knock it down but I think the other
reason that it's around is that off
target pathway it's off target from our
perspective you know of trying to knock
down one gene you know this micro RNA
pathway but cells have used it to do all
sorts of fine-tuning of gene expression
so in a way that you know it originally
evolved for this one purpose but cells
have co-opted it for other reasons
that's especially important in
developmental biology fine tuning a
whole bunch of genes just through the
use of a single sequence is a very
powerful rheostat for the cell great
question
okay so what i want to talk about is
what we my group actually does at the
broad and that's using CRISPR to study
gene function the way we do that is what
we call these pooled screens and I'm
going to briefly walk through what are
the steps of these pooled screens so
step one is you synthesize some alga
nucleotides using technology that's been
with us for a while so the technology
one would have used to synthesize a
microarray so you synthesize the malla
goads you then transfer those sequences
in
to a bunch of plasmids you then take
those plasmids and you make them into
virus and then you put that virus and
you put it into cells
okay so you've integrated the
information for the small RNA into the
cell
each cell now expresses one of these
sequences and knocks out one gene so now
I have a big population of cells each of
which you know is schematized by the
colors here has knocked out one gene out
of the 20,000 in the human genome you
then apply some selective pressure to
the cells either to enrich four cells
that have a particular property so
they'd be called a positive selection or
to look for cells that disappear from
the population that'd be a negative
selection just and I'll give two
examples of a positive selection but a
negative selection B for example what
genes are required for cells to grow so
if you knock out every gene in the human
genome
let your population of cells grow for
two weeks the ones that aren't there
anymore that guide RNA must have
targeted a gene that was essential for
growth so you could find what are all
the essential genes in cells so anyway
you let your time is your selective
pressure here you then perform PCR to
get that guide RNA sequence back out of
the cell sequence it with Illumina
sequencing technology or similar and at
the end you end up with an Excel
spreadsheet of well here all my guide
RNAs and this is how abundant they were
in the various populations that I put it
through and you'll see some examples of
that but this is the general workflow so
some of the work that we did with
Jennifer and Niccolo was really focused
on this first step of oligonucleotide
synthesis if you want to design against
a gene of interest okay so there's a lot
of variability in which sequence you can
pick so here's an example here's a gene
nf1 where we know what it does it's a
positive control for for a particular
assay that we have and each dot
represents a different guide RNA
targeting the gene nf1 okay CRISPR
technology you can essentially target
anywhere in the genome with relatively
few sequence constraints so we just made
every possible guide RNA against this
gene okay so here's the end terminus of
the gene here's the c-terminus of the
gene and on the y-axis is a measure of
the activity of that guy darn how good
was that guy at RNA it
actually knocking out the gene nf1 and
what you can see is this is just kind of
a mess right I mean there are some guy
in that work very well some guys that
work very poorly and the question is
prospectively how do we pick you know
when we want to synthesize dyed RNAs
against the entire human genome how do
we make sure for every gene in the
genome we're picking these and we're not
picking these so we generated a very
large data a relatively large data set
and we determined well what are the
sequence features that allow you to pick
from the top but not from the bottom and
if you want to know a lot of the details
of this awfully speak with Jennifer and
Niccolo but the most important part is
we made these rules and we then applied
them and we saw that they really
improved our ability to actually do
these screens so it's shown here is
again on the x-axis are basically some a
control phenotype where we know okay if
a guide RNA targets this gene
effectively then the cell should die
these are cells that are excuse me
targets that are essential for life so
genes in the ribosome genes and the
spliceosome genes in the proteasome or
RNA polymerase things that every cell
needs to survive so we can say okay if
we target these genes do the cells die
or not and then okay well what fraction
of guides actually work so this is an
area under the curve analysis and what
you can see is as we've gone through
different iterations of our library from
gecko v1 to gecko v2 to ivana than
Brunello
our area under the curves keep going up
so we're doing better and better with
our ability to design guide RNAs and
actually knock out the intended gene of
interest
okay so genome-wide pooled screens how
do we actually apply this okay what are
some examples how does this actually
work first off so in the GPP my platform
at the broad our job is to build good
perturbations to make good CRISPR
libraries to understand how the
technology works understand how to
deliver it and to have these libraries
that target every gene in the human
genome ready to go then we rely on
collaborators to build really good
models of biology right and an
experiment is only as good as the model
that you're using your model of diabetes
your model of infectious disease
whatever we then meet to discuss the
screen you know these folks have thereby
ecology of strength we have our
technology strength and we meet
generally we provide the perturbations
to the people so they don't need to
become expert in synthesizing libraries
or making virus or things like that
we're expert in that they then execute
the screen because they are expert in
there
funky cells that are derived from a
mouse brain or their primary cells that
they get from human patients or whatever
they know their model and then will
process the samples and the really cool
part is you know this is a very
iterative process so it's not toss over
the fence and then toss back over the
fence but a very iterative process where
we're working with people basically
throughout the duration of the screen
and at the end we get data and hits and
and that's all good so that's the model
by which we work and I think the real
benefit of this model is that we can
work with a lot of different
collaborators I'm gonna show two
examples I pretty good like this first
exam so there's the IKEA drawing of you
know do it yourself just get a friend so
this is with marine norovirus and what I
predicted so norovirus is cruise-ship
virus so when you ever read stories
about like cruise ships that needed to
dock early because norovirus swept
through you know that this is cruise
ship virus but what I really like this
I've never met these guys Robert and
Craig and skip their collaborators at
Washington University we've entirely
just spoken my phone and email and FedEx
packages back and forth you know we were
able to scale this screen platform to
their work without ever having to be in
physical proximity so we can work with a
lot of different groups on a lotta
different problems with this model so
they work on marrying norovirus and they
had a question well what are the genes
that are required for murine norovirus
to get into cells and to you know
undergo their viral life cycle so they
took these particular cells they put in
this pool of guide RNAs they then
challenged this mixed population of
cells with mirroring norovirus and the
vast majority of cells were infected
with norovirus and died okay so those
the guide RNAs that were in those cells
it had nothing to do with miry norovirus
in those cells died however there were a
small number of cells that survived so
we just sequenced well what are the
guide RNAs that were in the cells that
survived because these guide RNAs must
have knocked out a gene that was somehow
essential for Mearing norovirus to enter
the cells and then we
did that you know I usually don't use
pie charts but almost every single guide
RNA that was in this population at the
end targeted this one gene so you don't
need a lot of fancy statistical analysis
to say like okay this gene is a hit in
this screen this gene is likely involved
in meereen norovirus infection so we
identified a top hit and then we said
well okay how does this work so this is
a gene that is expressed on the cell
surface we could introduce an antibody
that bound to this gene that would block
the ability of norovirus to actually
bind to this gene on the surface and we
could see okay when we add in this
blocking antibody the cells now survive
okay that's a good piece of evidence we
can also express just the soluble part
so it doesn't stick in the membrane but
it just gets sent out into the media so
just the soluble part to act basically
act as a competitor for the endogenous
one and this soaks up all the norovirus
and again the cells survive okay
likewise we could do this in mice
so we now take mice that have a
compromised immune system and normally
when you challenge these mice with
norovirus the mice die kaplan-meier
survival curve the mice die however if
we pre treated the mice with this
soluble version of CD 300 LF so the same
thing that we used here we pretreat the
mice with soluble the mice then survived
all the mice survived totally flatline
they all survived challenged with
norovirus okay so and the really cool
part this is my favorite experiment we
were using murine norovirus because no
one really works with human norovirus we
showed that just by expressing the mouse
CD 300 LF in human cells but not more
human or GFP a control if we express
more of the mouse if we put the mouse
receptor on the surface now Mouse
norovirus can infect human cells so this
is both necessary and sufficient for
binding and entry into human cells which
is pretty cool so of course we're doing
some follow-up on this you know we're
making knockout mice and we're asking
that you know what are the therapeutic
implications for very norovirus entry
okay so that's one example of you know
we had the the question was pretty
simple
what is the receptor from your norovirus
no one knew and in a relatively short
timeframe we were able to screen every
gene in the human genome and find aha
this is the receptor okay another
example this one is particularly
exciting so this is using again this
approach of pooled screening but now
we're doing it in vivo we're actually
doing screening in a mouse and we're
doing it for oncology immunotherapy
target discovery these are people I have
met with a lot their colleagues over at
Dana Farber that we've been working with
for a long time so as anyone weather
professionally or not you know cancer
has affected everyone in some way or
another
and what's truly in cancer therapy is
that we're making these new small
molecules okay that are effective but
resistance arises nearly universally
with these small molecule inhibitors so
here's an example of Vemma RAF nib a
great small molecule it is specific
provider men de specificity for killing
melanoma cells that have a particular
mutation okay and you can see that in
the survival curve so this is sort of
the previous standard of care treatment
and patients with metastatic melanoma
quickly succumb to their disease however
you tweet you treat with vemma Rathnam
and you see an increased survival right
there's a big no problem fitting a laser
pointer in between these curves of the
kaplan-meier right so does really well
but notice where it ends up right people
are not you have progression-free
survival a win no doubt but not a cure
okay so these small molecules and you
can see that this is a patient that
prison this was this is an early
clinical trial this is a patient with
metastatic melanoma everywhere okay
treat with vemma Rathnam and you know a
couple months later like this is
miraculous right but then a couple
months after that resistance arose and
this patient did succumb to metastatic
melanoma not long after so that's that's
the the pictorial version of what this
kaplan-meier survival curve is showing
great early responses but the ultimate
outcome tends to be the same however
harnessing the immune system
offers a fundamentally different
approach of doing this so it turns out
that our immune system is actually
pretty good at recognizing many tumors
and is actively trying to clear out
tumors as they form but the immune
system the tumor evolves ways to put a
break on the immune system
so normally the t-cell so T cells are
effector cells in our immune system will
interact with a tumor cell okay and one
of the interactions is here where the
tumor cell will express this gene called
PDL 1 and PDL 1 will inhibit the T cell
so the expression of this tells the T
cell and the T cell recognizing it says
don't eat me ok you should not eat me
however if you put in an antibody that
either blocks this receptor on the T
cell or blocks this antigen on the tumor
cell now the T cell will attack this
tumor cell so that's the idea behind
immunotherapy but what's particularly
exciting about immunotherapy is the
shape of the survival curve so again
what's shown in the dotted line is
standard chemotherapy which shown in the
two solid lines are just two different
doses of one of these user known as
checkpoint blockade inhibitors okay and
you see a very different kaplan-meier
survival curve the first thing you can
notice is that there's not a lot of
difference up here right there's not you
know when you when you go back to the
Bema afternoon you very early on start
to see a big difference in what's going
on early but you don't see that with
these checkpoint blockades and it is you
know where you want to call it
serendipity or terrifying early clinical
trials of checkpoint blockade inhibitors
were almost stopped because they didn't
see anything happening early on okay but
they did let it go on and what they see
now okay is two things okay first you
know and this is what I mean by both the
promise and the challenge so the promise
is this cures you know there are people
who are on checkpoint blockade
inhibitors that for all intents and
purposes have been cured of metastatic
melanoma
ten years ago was a death sentence okay
but now some fraction of people are
being as far as we can tell cured by
this therapy which is incredible but
here's the challenge right you know this
is what 25% of people respond 75% don't
respond yeah so that is absolutely a
massive clinical undertaking uh there
you know there are a lot of these small
molecule inhibitors that have been
developed there are a lot of these
checkpoint inhibitors that have now been
developed and doing the combinatoric of
can we match different antibodies
together can we match antibodies with
small molecules and seen what you know
does that improve your response that is
absolutely being done right now by
basically ever a pharma company on the
planet yeah yeah and I think there's
there's two there's two check there's
multiple challenges to that the the most
interesting one is that there are now
almost too many drugs on the market to
really saturate the combinatorial space
in clinical trials
so we sort of like need more sick people
which is not obviously what we need at
all but you know it the ability to can
you predict in advance
what combinations might be effective
before you start the clinical trial is a
major hurdle in doing any of this drug
development stuff because again you know
the what's great is we have so many
treatment options but that also means
the combinatoric some it explodes yeah
this is a lot of variation how people
are responding what do we what I know I
model of what's going on is that people
are different you know cuz it sound like
science it sounds like kind of like
physics maybe I think the same thing
would happen every time but maybe it's
that they're less different kinds of
diseases that we kind of cool same thing
will people a different way what yeah
that is that is a great that gets to the
heart of one of the challenges of drug
development right it's okay how could
you you know what maybe another way of
phrasing that question is what was
different about these tumors where if we
had stratified earlier on we had said
okay if you expand you so we now know
that if you express higher levels of
this or this then you're more likely to
respond
whereas if you know your tumour cells
aren't expressing any of this then
you're not likely to respond so it's
learning more and more about that so we
can in advance tailor the effective
treatment to the patient so that's kind
of why we're doing gene function
discovery to do answer exactly that
question so we did another pooled screen
where we took a library of guide RNAs we
then put them into a mouse that has an
immune system obviously the studying the
immune system there are many aspects of
it that you can't do in human cell
culture because it's tremendous
cell-cell interactions there's something
that you have to do in a mouse model to
really capture it and then we were
looking for two classes of genes the in
the in the case of immunity challenge
the guides that become enriched well
these are potential resistance
mechanisms you know these are guide RNAs
that when this gene is lost the cell no
longer responds to the immunotherapy the
immunotherapy likewise the ones that are
depleted well these are potential
additional immunotherapy targets these
are genes that the tumor cell needs in
order to avoid the immune system so we
did that and again this is just point
out that we did it in mice and what we
were very excited about is so each of
the this is a histogram of where all the
different guide RNAs scored again
whether they were depleted or enriched
and what we saw is that our guide RNAs
against PDL one so basically what serves
as a positive control we're very much
depleted so this suggests that the mouse
model that we're using is able to
recapitulate exactly what we see in the
human patients namely that if you
eliminate PDL one in this case with
CRISPR but in patients with an antibody
that blocks it you actually deplete that
tumor and of course the very exciting
question then is well what are all these
other genes doing you know why are they
scoring and what are they and are they
potential immunotherapy targets and that
is me this is a very active area of
interest in the hanging lab okay so if
we didn't already know it now we did
know but if we didn't know it we would
have discovered that PDL one is a good
target so that that's good that
validates the model validates the
approach and of course what are all
these other genes doing and then on the
other end of the screen you're getting
this question of you know triaging
patient groups
well the genes that
are enriched okay the guide RNA is that
fall on this end of the spectrum you
know maybe these rent these might
represent potential mechanisms of
therapy resistance weather resistance
that evolves during the course of
treatment or it's a starting state okay
these things are not going to respond to
this therapy because they they lack this
gene so they're not going to be
responsive okay so those are two
examples of what we really mean by
functional genomics and I think they
Jennifer yeah we're we're on a
fundamental level it's not understood it
is definitely understood
phenomenologically like one sees this
generally with oh you know basically
every small molecule that you treat you
can get models of resistance where is
with the immune system ajan with the
immune system that you know it is it is
a far more elegant and evolved system
than just some small molecule that
happens to inhibit you know one gene so
there could very much be sort of a
combinatorial effect of the immune
system reckonings odd this is a tumor
and then marshalling all the resources
of the immune system in a way where it
can evolve with the tumor basically to
keep it in check in a way that a small
molecule can okay so functional we
really have to put together these three
things you know we have a model you know
cell culture models mouse models we have
perturbations so I've talked a lot about
CRISPR
but you know there's a big long list of
perturbations that were able to put it
cells and then of course you have assays
and I showed you an example two examples
of using survival as an assay we turned
challenge with norovirus or challenge
with the immune system as an assay to
select for viability but there are other
assays you can do flow cytometry based
assays for example and it's really when
you put all three of these together that
you really have a good experiment where
you can actually learn things about gene
function so with that I'd like to thank
everyone that's part of the GPP team
it's a group of about 35 folks we have
people involved in technology
development like me library production
outreach actual screening software
engineering and computation and in
particular these
folks that work directly with me they
have a lot of patience that everyday and
our collaborators not not least to which
Jennifer and Niccolo both for being
wonderful collaborators for the last two
years and tolerating my biology speak as
I tolerate their computational speak but
we like each other and so we talk
through it and then figure stuff out and
make progress and with that I'm happy to
take any more questions thank you